every Friday we are taking the time to
answer your most pressing questions
you've got a lot of them about the
coronavirus at least 19 states and
Washington DC announced new cases of a
mysterious illness and children that is
potentially related to the virus so this
raises major concerns as the u.s. starts
to reopen and president Trump pushes to
open schools CBS News senior medical
correspondent dr. Tara nurullah joins us
I note the title change kudos to you
Tara
Narula on that so before we answer
audience questions we want to talk about
an alert from the CDC that has talking
about a potentially deadly syndrome in
children with corona virus what can you
tell us about that well again we've been
talking about this for the last couple
days and what they did is basically
create a case definition so we have a
better idea of how to define cases and
that includes fever in children that
lasts more than 24 hours laboratory
evidence of inflammation clinically
severe disease that requires
hospitalization and the involvement of
more than two organ systems in addition
to that the child would have to have
evidence on labs of infection with kovat
or previous infection with Kovan or
exposure in the last four weeks to
someone with kovat and finally it has to
be ruled out that there's no other
possible alternative diagnosis if you
meet all of those criteria you would be
defined as having this multi-system
inflammatory syndrome and it's important
because if doctors begin to report I was
gonna say if doctors can report this to
state and local health officials we can
get a better picture of what this
disease and syndrome really looks like
all right everybody's concerned about
their kids Heather asked this question
for you how and when will it be safe for
our children to go outside on a play
date I wish I had the answer for Heather
and sometimes the answer is we don't
know and unfortunately in this case we
really don't know you know we're still
talking about social distancing we're
talking about it in schools and in
potentially summer camps so the idea of
really having kids in these close
quarters right now is probably not going
to happen at least for the next several
weeks I think two months
but it's really remains to be seen
Lindsay wants to know what kind of masks
are best for kids because I see parents
outside sometimes their kids are wearing
masks and sometimes they're not
so what masks are best for kids a mask
that a kid will wear Gail so some of
these homemade some of these homemade
cloth masks are perfect
the CDC actually has a website we went
to it ourselves and we used an old
t-shirt I have an example here we cut it
out one where you don't have to sew one
where you can sew it and it fits very
nicely on the child's face you can wash
it it's breathable and you can use
something like a t-shirt or a pillow or
a blanket you want to reserve those n95
and surgical masks for the healthcare
workers and if you make the homemade
mask the kids can decorate them
important to note that kids under two
should not be wearing a mask
as just as a side note yeah that's what
I was gonna ask you do you think
children all children should wear masks
and you answer that people are starting
to think about school openings although
most of the schools are closed right now
but Myra is asking this how can we
safely social distance elementary school
students and how can teachers prepare
for schools reopening well it's gonna
require a lot of planning and a lot of
creativity and we are seeing it done in
other countries one big thing is going
to be staggering so staggering arrival
and dismissal times staggering when kids
for example go to the library or in the
hallway or have lunch and even
staggering days when you have schools so
some kids might go to school Monday
Wednesday Friday some kids might go in
the morning or the afternoon then
there's going to be redesign of
classrooms so that you have the desks
sort of all back-to-back six feet apart
and even face shields on the desks and
finally avoiding those large gatherings
like assemblies all right Thank You Tara